today we are going to talk about how to
prevent hair loss
but not just how to prevent hair loss
but when you grow your hair to make sure
that it's it's full and prevent the loss
of hair focusing on this one very
important common problem
and this involves a type of testosterone
a very strong type of a testosterone
called
DHT several common medications out there
for hair loss their mechanism is to
block an enzyme so you can lower the
amount of DHT that interacts with your
hair because when this very powerful
form of testosterone interacts with the
receptor okay in your scalp your hair
just does not grow that well if it does
grow it's going to be very miniature or
tiny so I wanted to create a video only
on this one topic of how to restore the
receptor for DHT because really the
problem is that this receptor is turned
up and that makes DHT more sensitive and
it is a genetic issue for a lot of
people but there are things that you can
do about it okay because one of the
problems people have when they're doing
the medication is that it blocks DHT too
much and then they end up having side
effects like decrease libido erectile
dysfunction depression things like that
but for this problem it has everything
to do with the receptor for DHT in your
scalp it is a genetic sensitivity
problem so how do we regulate it and
turn it down a little bit so it's not
overactive now now there are a lot of
herbs out there that you can get and try
salt Palmetto and some of these work for
some people and some sometimes they
don't work I want to talk more about
some additional things that you can do
that involve epigenetics which is
basically above genes okay it's things
that you can do and take and eat that
can keep these genetic variations in
check and keep them working to your
advantage so there are five main factors
that we're going to focus on today
so what is the first factor that can
worsen this problem how do we deal with
it well it's called hypoxia what is
hypoxia that is a condition where you
have a lack of oxygen okay into your
scalp now what can cause a lack of
oxygen three things one anemia
two inflammation and three a lack of
exercise so of course you have to look
at the situation to see if you have a
problem with any of these three do you
exercise on a regular basis if you don't
it might be a good idea to do it do you
potentially have anemia okay if you do
um the two types of anemia that people
have would be an iron anemia or a B12
Anemia iron and b12 both come from red
meat if you are a vegetarian or a vegan
chances are you may be deficient in
these two unless you take them in the
right form but there's other causes of
anemia as well and these also relate to
genetics in which case if you look at
your genes the recommendation would be
beef liver or liver grass-fed liver
tablets something like that but the one
you would really need to take would be
called methylcobolamine not the
cyanocobalamine okay so that's just a
tip with that other reasons for anemia
is you don't have enough stomach acid
for some reason and how do you know if
you don't have enough stomach acid well
you're going to have more indigestion
you might have acid reflux things like
that that would be indication that you
need just to take betaine hydrochloride
to acidify stomach and that could help
you exercise anemia and then
inflammation okay
A lot of people are consuming the wrong
foods and they're inflamed their whole
body is inflamed the most commonly
consumed food that raises the
inflammation in your body
has to do with omega-6 fatty acids I I
harp on this over and over and over
again you just want to get those
unsaturated oils out of the diets I'm
talking about the soy the corn oil the
canola oil the cottonseed oil the
safflower oil get them out of the diet
because they're just no good instead
replace them with omega-3 fatty acids
cod liver oil would be very beneficial
the other natural anti-inflammatory that
would help you with inflammation
as well as hair loss is vitamin D if
you're going to take vitamin D don't
ever take less than 10 000 I use okay
there's many reasons for this but most
people are deficient and they usually
have a lot of barriers to absorb vitamin
D and so taking more is one solution now
number two vitamin D okay vitamin D
directly can help turn down the
sensitivity of that receptor and a
vitamin D deficiency could create more
problems with DHT affecting your hair so
again this is just a double reason to
take vitamin D to reduce inflammation
and also just to help you directly with
this receptor I would recommend a
minimum of 10 000 IUS but you may want
to take twenty thousand IUS there are
people that just do this alone and all
of a sudden they noticed their hair is
coming back it is virtually impossible
to get your vitamin D from food and many
people just don't get it from the Sun
anymore so they take it as a supplement
and the third thing is an amino acid
called a lysine okay a lysine a lot of
people take L-lysine for growing their
hair back and it's very effective remedy
why does it work well it works on the
receptor okay it helps regulate the
receptor for that ght so there's a
couple of things to do you can take it
as a supplement or you can just eat the
food that is high in L-lysine and that
would be it's kind of a crossover to
what I just said animal products Meats
red meat things like that it could be
other proteins as well like chicken Fish
seafood eggs
but L-lysine is low in nuts grains beans
seeds Okay so if you're eating a lot of
those things and not any animal products
then maybe you want to switch over or at
the very least start taking that amino
acid a lysine on an empty stomach
because it competes with other amino
acids and number four deficiency of
insulin can worsen this problem
so we need to increase insulin to help
you with this receptor problem to help
regulate the sensitivity of the receptor
now this may oppose all the different
videos I've talked about where insulin
is bad you should lower your insulin etc
etc and let me just clarify because I
just put a video out on this topic they
talked about the problem with insulin is
not insulin it's insulin resistance that
develops because you're raising insulin
so high the body starts to block it and
you end up with a insulin deficiency
okay and so when I say raise insulin
what I'm saying is to do it by fixing
insulin resistance and that way you'll
get the appropriate amount of insulin
into that receptor insulin is an
anabolic hormone and actually makes
things grow and when we're dealing with
the synthesis of hair we need more
insulin to the roots of your head and
insulin resistance is one big problem
that's not only behind hair loss but a
lot of other issues so how do we
increase insulin by fixing insulin
resistance how do we do that am I going
a low carb diet and we do intermittent
fasting okay this is why metformin
actually helps with hair growth because
metformin works on the insulin receptor
and it actually improves this resistance
problem increasing more insulin to make
the connection so the whole circuit can
work right and number five correcting
the right amount of
estrogen okay women who are pregnant
then have their baby notice hair loss
right after pregnancy mainly because
they get this severe drop in estrogen
also when they have their cycle when
they have their period their hair starts
falling out
that's the lowest point of the menstrual
cycle right when they have their period
and also when women go through menopause
they have a lower amount of estrogen
right and they get hair loss so how do
we increase estrogen well it depends
what's causing it but you could start
consuming phytoestrogens like flaxseed
that can help balance estrogen sprouted
legumes could help in a certain way if
you're going through menopause and you
want to increase estrogen you want to
actually support the adrenal glands okay
they have two of them and the way you do
that is maybe you take an adaptogen
called ashwagandha and you also want to
make sure that you have enough
cholesterol in the diet you know like
egg yolks and butter because that's the
precursors to make all these hormones
including estrogen and other sex
hormones anyway I wanted to cover
something very specific to hair loss
which is very common this over
sensitivity to this receptor for DHT so
you have some other things to look at to
get your hair back and there's actually
a lot more to talk about regarding hair
that go into other things if you haven't
seen my other video on hair loss that is
very important I put that up right here
check it out